Hey, it's Pete.
I'm here in Silicon Valley today and I'm talking
to Vida Ha, who's the co-founder of Ifeelgoods.
Hey, Vida.
VIDA: Hi
PETE: How are you doing today?
VIDA: Great.
PETE: Are you excited?
VIDA: Yes
PETE: You pumped?
PETE: Good.
So in this episode of g33ktalk, we're going
to talk to Vita about her technology stack
and we have some really interesting things
we're going to talk about.
Some infrastructure stuff, we're going to
talk about how to stop and prevent online
fraud, which is pretty cool.
We're going to talk about some various data
related stuff that you guys are dabbling in
and using, which is cool.
And yeah, we're just going to generally geek
out and have a good time.
Are you ready?
VIDA: Sounds great
PETE: Alright.
So, Vita, you were previously at Google, right?
VIDA: Yes
PETE: And now your role here is co-founder
of Ifeelgoods
VIDA: And Lead Engineer
PETE: Lead Engineer.
Okay, cool.
So tell us a little bit about Ifeelgoods,
what you guys do, just so we have some context
to as what your application is and what you
guys are doing.
VIDA: Yes.
We are a digital goods incentive platform.
That's big jargon that basically says we power
the redemption of free digital goods.
Things like Facebook credits, Skype minutes,
E-gift cards, anything that's instantly redeemable,
that can be delivered electronically, so that
retailers can offer them to consumers in place
of discounts.
PETE: Okay.
So give me a typical use case, like how would
a customer or where would a customer see your
service in a purchase flow for e-commerce
site, for instance?
VIDA: Right, so they would see banners that
we would host on the retailers' side that
talks about the offers.
So maybe in place of free shipping, you would
get $5 worth of free Facebook credits instead.
And then at the end of the flow, after the
receipt confirmation page, you'd see a widget
that's hosted by us.
We actually do the whole front end part of
it also.
You'd Facebook connect, click it, we know
who your identity is and then we deposit credits
directly into your account.
PETE: Okay.
So this could be an incentive, alongside an
actual, it could be a hardware that's purchased,
or some sort of incentive or digital promotion
that is just powered by you guys.
VIDA: Exactly.
You get to use the Facebook credits immediately
today even if it takes a week for your new
shoes or whatever to arrive.
PETE: Okay, okay, cool.
Tell me a little bit about your technology
stack.
What are you guys using and what are you built
on?
VIDA: We are using Ruby on Rails as our web
development framework on top of Amazon, EC2
services all over the board.
We also have to know Facebook APIs, all the
things like that.
PETE: Okay.
You mentioned before that you guys are using
a lot of different parts of the AWS stack,
run me through those quickly.
VIDA: There is, EC2, which is the servers
that we actually run.
There's RDS which is our main SQL style database.
We also use Simple DB, which is a more, a
more new flavor kind of SQL database.
And then there's also S3 for storage.
So we use that both for any kind of large
data that we want to save for offline processing
as well as just images, creatives, like things
that go on our website on our redemption flow.
And then we use a couple of the other services.
There is the load balancing layer that we
use automatically with Amazon, Elastic MapReduce.
PETE: Cool.
So you're all the way in the cloud.
Do you have any servers at all?
VIDA: No.
PETE: Do you have a backup server somewhere?
You can back up things on Amazon.
PETE: Alright.
A lot of people use it for that, right?
S3 is cheap.
VIDA: They triplicate everything, typically.
So I'm not worried about it.
PETE: Okay, Cool.
Have you ever had an Amazon outage, just out
of curiosity?
VIDA: No.
PETE: No?
Alright.
VIDA: We've been lucky enough to not be hit
with that problem.
PETE: Cool.
Well if Amazon is listening, I'm sure they
would like to hear that.